it's been almost three weeks since
Croatia adopted the Euro as its currency
and people aren't happy
I felt the increase in food prices from
January the 1st I like to eat a lot and
that's a problem because food is
expensive compared to the salaries as
they are currently a lot of people I
know have started looking for another
job
we all felt the price increase at least
30 percent higher for everything
some Traders say they are rounding up
prices when converting the old currency
the kuna into Euros others have denied
the increases but gracious consumer
protection body says the government is
proof some Outlets are marking up Goods
a few days ago we got a statement from
the minister of economy that inspections
were carried out and that up to 40
percent of retailers were raising prices
unjustifiably
the government has warned it will find
retailers that fail to reduce their
prices to pre-euro levels but the
Traders Association has dismissed the
government accusations saying its
members are not increasing prices to
make a profit but because of the rising
cost of raw materials and energy either
way despite the economic benefits for
Croatia of joining The single currency
it's coming at a cost
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera